we got the live stream pulled up and I
just really don't care what these people
have to say like you know it's like
she's like reading some book or
something it's like come on dude and the
funny thing about the the past six votes
is just all of the grand standing the
smirking the smug
you know what man here we go here so the
the chair has examined the proceedings
what is this what is she gonna say I'll
come to this in a second and we'll we'll
get the volume up but here's the big
story six Kevin McCarthy loses a sixth
vote as the GOP struggles to agree on a
leader struggles simple not McCarthy and
you've got you've got uh there's so much
man Crenshaw called the the resistors he
called them terrorists I was uh I
thought that he called them something
else and and then someone else called
him terrorists maybe uh what's it
kinzinger call them terrorists that's
what I heard was a kid or not Crenshaw
yeah that's right maybe maybe I got it
mixed up Crenshaw did use a slur though
if you want to consider the words I'm
pretty sure said terrorists I thought he
did but actually I got to give the shout
out to the krasenstein brothers because
I think they're the ones who actually
tweeted it and so I'm not gonna no
offense of the Crescent team Brothers he
says uh
Dan Crenshaw referred to the 20
Republicans against McCarthy as
terrorists you hear that Lauren bobert
Matt Gates got Parry terrorists okay
well you know let's fact Jack that
because uh no offense of the Crescent
Brothers but they're not the the most
prominent journalists right yeah so yeah
was it I don't even know how to find
this what I when I read the tweet it was
Adam kinzinger did a long thing and at
the end he was like called them
legislative terrorists in his tweet and
then Adam and then I thought that uh
they all should be booed desktop body
might be super loud
as a gentleman from California
fight fight oh
what is this is anybody even there
anymore
they just uh made a motion
Nays or order
for what
please go I don't know we weren't
listening we should do it
we got to do an IRL live from Congress
a sufficient
the yeas and nays are ordered members
will record their votes by electronic
device
did we see what they were voting on
I didn't expect them to go to a motion
immediately or government's a joke it's
like we're doing the intros and
everything when hasn't it been a joke
this [ __ ] is so funny dude like the fact
that this can just go into Sesame Street
without anyone batting an eye is pretty
hilarious
all right here we go a motion to adjourn
there it is oh they're going home
welcome to the live show ladies and
gentlemen coverage of people who won't
do their jobs those lazy bums get back
to work yeah but look look the Nays the
Democrats are saying they don't want to
leave come on well they want McCartney
No no no hey the Democrats plus the
holdouts if the if the Republican
holdouts say nay then they ain't going
anywhere so they vote on everything this
is just voting to go home and sleep yeah
time remaining are we gonna sit here we
got to sit here you know this is this is
the challenging thing about today is
this history yeah it's the last it was
it's been a hundred years to the day
that there has been something like this
well yesterday
when the house did not elect a speaker
100 years 1923 and so here we are again
and Kevin McCarthy has lost six ballots
now they're trying to go home
lazy bums and the world economic Forum
by the way just called this race last
night if you go on their website you can
look at their member Kevin McCarthy and
it says that he's listed as the majority
leader of the House of Representatives
Majority Leader is the Republicans are
in the majority and he's the leader of
the Republican party that's that's a
fact officially uh but but still it's
interesting to see the world economic
Forum here
I got to correct this yes yeah he's the
majority leader whether he's speaker or
not he's the majority leader right now
to get voted in no so uh that's an RNC
thing Majority Leader means all right so
the Republicans are the majority right
that means they're the majority the
leader of the party GOP is Kevin
McCarthy Kevin McCarty McCarthy was
elected by the by the Republican
National Committee or whatever
organization so he is the leader of the
majority speaker of the house is totally
different I'm seeing a bunch of people
be like the world economic Forum says
he's speaker and I look at it says it
says Majority Leader he is they won the
majority he's the leader of the
Republicans in the house you don't got
to like him you don't gotta like the guy
but that's why everyone's marching in
lockstep behind him right because he's
just in charge of the establishment
machine so nobody dares go up against
them that's why they're calling you know
Matt Gates bobert and all and the
freedom caucus terrorists yeah to
clarify on that uh Adam kinzinger has
called them legislative terrorists a
year ago a year and a half ago so the
Stan Crenshaw thing might be real I just
haven't seen the The Source I haven't
seen the actual tweet so far one
Republican nay I hope the Republicans
don't let them go home net Gates Don't
let him go home what's this movie like
is um 12 good men or something you know
what I'm talking about where they can't
leave until they have a verdict are they
going to wait 12 minutes and then at the
end everybody's gonna say 40 like a
bunch of people will say yay and make it
or a bunch of people will say nay so
they're like they want to make them
think they get to stay in their last
minute they're trying to go home yeah
well they probably weren't able to
broker a deal right we want Sesame look
the Democrats don't want to leave I
think that's hilarious turn it off so
what would happen if they don't leave
they gotta they gotta vote they gotta
keep it and then if kinsiger is not
going to get it which he doesn't seem to
what will happen they just keep voting
nine times
yeah McCarthy they got to keep going
until they get someone
and so those are there are rumors that
uh McCarthy is gonna try and talk with
some Democrats or something's gonna
happen and a lot of people are scared
they're like oh no if a hundred and what
108 109 Democrats and 100
non-republicans decide to come together
they can nominate someone like Liz
Cheney because that'll get them over the
threshold for the vote I just don't see
that happening that's crazy but you know
maybe what am I supposed so what happens
someone just changes their mind
overnight or they get threatened or like
I'm gonna kill you if you don't like
what goes on what those are making deals
between that's the only thing it's like
so obvious where it's like we're gonna
vote literally five minutes later and
now we change our mind because wow like
what what realistically happens in order
for somebody to be like I guess I
changed well so look if they do a vote
and then you know I'm sitting here and
then they're like everybody watch
McCarthy and then I don't then it's like
okay we're not gonna go home we're not
gonna get done and you're not gonna win
just vote McCarthy some people just go
ah fine whatever this is literally like
something that can affect you know the
everyday persons like I just want to go
home and eat so I'm just well yeah in
two days but more importantly it's kind
of like look you're not gonna win and so
someone might be like okay fine here's
the crazy thing though Kevin McCarthy's
losing votes right he got night he lost
19 votes the first time then he lost 20
then he lost 21. he's just slowly losing
more people it's time for the McCarthy
faction to lies they have no loyalty
it's only fear and the people opposing
McCarthy are the people who are voting
on principle saying we do not want an
establishment shill who worked against
the America first movement against
Donald Trump even if Donald Trump
endorses him I'll tell you what's really
interesting Donald Trump came out and
said everybody should vote for McCarthy
and Matt Gates said sad yo Trump trumps
retired that's that that's the way I'm
putting it I think Trump's coming out
and endorsing them because he's like
just leave me alone you know just just
just call off your dogs look they raided
his house the fed's kick his door in I'm
sure when that happened he said please
please just stop I just want to play
golf and they were like okay endorse our
guys play a ball with us and you can and
I think that's what Trump's doing but
why is he's running to be president of
the United States then why is he putting
himself out there why is he still he has
to shoot social he doesn't have to or
maybe what's him saying maybe he wins
and now he's not a different person he
comes out with nfts look I know he made
a lot of money off I bought a few I made
a couple bucks but his Bae like right
now I'm seeing people people have been
super chatting me and chatting earlier
and commenting that Trump sold out right
supporting McCarthy look man
the media makes Donald Trump look like
an Oompa Loompa they they brighten his
face they saturate it so he gets real
dark orange I've seen it in person and
then he goes to those same journals it
says I'm gonna give you the perfect
interview the exclusive you can you can
report whatever you want why would you
do that right Kevin McCarthy calls me
Putin puppet Kevin McCarthy blames him
for January 6. Kevin McCarthy works
against Michael Kenneth and then Trump's
like I'm gonna endorse the guy who's
trying who's trying to ruin me so you're
saying that he's retired he's like I'm
done fighting these people you know
right more than retired though right
right if you're retired you just don't
you don't do anything so it's more than
retired what you're saying but I feel
tired and controlled retired and uh
blackmailed [ __ ] what because why
would you even say anything you know I
mean I wonder I wonder because why do
anything so they raided his house the
FBI raised his house okay it's not going
to stop yeah he goes to them and says
how do I make it stop they say endorse
us and he goes okay would that be black
yes sir yes sir not if the government's
doing it the government can't charge
itself can it right I mean I guess it
can but like we investigated ourselves
and finally did nothing wrong but if I
came to you and I was like what can I do
and you're like do this thing and then I
and then with I be black would you be
blackmailing if I asked you what I
should do the government routinely goes
to people and says we will drop the
criminal charges against you if you do
this thing for us isn't that funny how
they're a lot I don't think they should
even be allowed to do that I mean it's
it's a challenging thing to argue but
this idea of like so I'm watching that
movie Molly's game you ever see it 2017.
it's really good yeah it's about the
woman around the poker room yeah poker
games and part of the movie is the feds
say to her we will give you all your
money back that we seized
you will which will you know it's five
million dollars we illegally took from
you without unconstitutionally we'll
give it back
you won't go to jail but you got to turn
over the communications that you have
with other people that aren't criminal
in nature so these like she has
Communications with people about their
family and personal lives and they're
like we want all of the forensic Imaging
from your devices she's like no way like
that's not even related to any crimes
and they're like give it to us and you
get your money back for what reason it
was civil forfeiture they stole her
money so the government does it that's
what they do yo remember that story
where was like somebody was walking
through the airport with fifteen
thousand dollars and we took it they
just took it it's like what never heard
that but and it was like the cops were
all smiling and the dog sniffed at the
money in their stacks of cash and it's
like carrying money is not a crime dude
yeah civil asset forfeiture is extremely
disturbing that if you have what is it
what's the you know what the limit is
over how much amount of cash on you and
then also the cops can just be like it's
hours yeah it's like it's probably ten
thousand dollars they consider a
probable cause of a crime or something
if you have a lot of money well they're
supposed to investigate if it's related
to any crime or not but many police
departments just keep it for themselves
and then use it in their budgets and
they buy themselves luxury vehicles and
a lot of other things that are just uh
egregious so yeah I mean what else did
you expect to the government to do other
than uh conducting theft that's pretty
much what the government does all the
time anyway so uh you know well well
hold on it's not theft anymore it's more
like a
no no no no no no hold on it's like a
when if the government were to take
something from you you could call it
theft right right but what if the
government takes your stuff destroys it
and then prints money which devalues
your currents like what would that be
counterfeiting
well cause like here's the point modern
monetary policy monetary Theory they
don't tax you to use your tax dollars to
buy stuff they just make money right
they tax you to control inflation
because they're making money right so
they found a way to take money out of
your bank account without you realizing
taking money so is that really it is it
is a kind of theft I guess right well
we've kind of agreed to it unfortunately
by just by holding it here I don't know
you might have agreed to it yeah
especially when you get pulled over by
the police and and just be cheering and
you'll get all happy it's but but no no
no no no one signed the social contract
no no no no hold on hold on what we
agree to is that we have a subscription
service called government that's what we
we quote unquote agree to by living here
the general perception of the American
people is that you take a percentage of
my income to cover the cost of roads and
police that's not what they're doing
they're creating money through Modern
monetary policy and fractional Reserve
banking without you knowing and they're
spending more money than you realize
from you so we didn't agree
we're the people through security
circuitous means they have created a
system where they just create money
spend it however they want nobody agreed
to give 1.7 trillion dollars in this big
Omnibus spending Bill nobody agreed to
give Ukraine these billions of dollars
they just do it yeah yeah Taxation and
stuff then it's a way to pretty much
keep everyone in line in order to keep
people poor you know what you do a
direct Democratic vote right now on
sending funding to Ukraine it loses
period for sure there's there's no way
you walk here's what we're going to do
how about we we I used to do free
canvassing I go out in the street the
microphone and I ask people to give me
20 bucks for Ukraine
guess what yeah you're not good no some
people would right some people
definitely would but most people would
say no of course not liberals or
whatever right right or Republicans
they'd say no it doesn't matter no it
really just depends on how good you are
at selling so you know we'll see because
some people would totally do it I
understand but uh let's say let's let's
say not 20 bucks 20 I'll say this how
much do you make per week and they'll
say like oh um you know I work at
Starbucks I do 15 bucks an hour right I
get about 500 bucks after you know I I
after everything it's like all right
I want 150 for Ukraine they're gonna say
no way dude of course no way whoa whoa
whoa
whoa it's not about what you asked for
it's about what we get to do we get to
take it from you it's a privilege yeah
it's a privilege man all right here
where are we at here on motion to
adjourn oh man
32 Republicans haven't voted yet 13
Democrats 200 Democrats say nay no no
adjourned dude I bet the one Republican
voted no I bet the Republicans are
intentionally waiting just to screw over
just to make those people like they're
like giving them hope false hope and
then at the very end like with 30
seconds 20 seconds left they're all
going to be like no no they're not going
to vote oh you know why you can choose
you could not you could not it's not no
vote is is one of the options so they
just don't vote and the Democrats take
it and that means you can't they don't
get to adjourn this is fun they're
voting everything what do you got you
guys want eggs tomorrow vote what are
you guys looking for motion to get
Blimpies for lunch
crazy the eyes
no secret bro like they get to talk to
each other and almost threaten you in
real life like in real time like the
[ __ ] that we like talk about as
conspiracy we're seeing it right now
they're like look here you [ __ ] you
know what I mean they go right up to you
right now they're like I see you haven't
voted yet whatever it is we're
witnessing yeah you're right I've never
seen this [ __ ] it's my point I don't I
don't know if can they not intermingle
before voting or no they can but you've
got 15 minutes there's there's no way
each member knows how other members
voted I know if I vote and you vote and
I go up to you and we don't know each
and I say look here Tim someone's gonna
kick me out that [ __ ] if they know that
someone's uncomfortable I think it's the
chairs like they have a button don't
they on the chair or something like yeah
it's an electrical button no maybe not
because are those chairs assigned are
they assigned chairs I don't know how
that works dude you know what I think
about Congress I just think it's full of
people who are like or better follow the
rules homie I have to wear a shirt no I
better wear a tie yeah totally I feel
like it's the opposite I feel like the
worst kids you knew in high school not
like worse as in society like we dropped
out and that's like they're doing great
my friends that like drop they're doing
great but all the intellects I feel like
that's this that's like I'm better than
everyone I'm a genius I'm intelligent
that's what I'm saying I'm saying these
people all go in and they're like but we
have to do things this way but the
speaker says I have to do it there's a
handful of people they're aware of the
rules and like Lauren bobert brought her
gun in I think in like Marjorie Taylor
green didn't want to wear a mask there
are a handful of people who are like get
your rules out of there man right stupid
I understand they're playing ball but
then behind the scenes I from what I
know they get drunk here we go here we
go we got we got a minute 15. it's a
close vote it's a close one minute oh
they're all coming in I know all the
yays pouring in with a minute left
there's still six Democrats haven't
voted yet they want to leave one of
these sports leagues needs to step it up
because like the fact that this is more
exciting than any sporting event I've
watched someone needs to step it up bro
like and I'm a sports fan our our public
servants going to leave for the night
yes we got 50 side vote yeah side bets
25 people I wonder I want to one in chat
if you think they're gonna stay if you
go to like Hollywood Casino down the
road I wonder if you can bet on this I
don't think you can yeah I bet if you go
to the sports book on everything yep
they got a C-SPAN just a C-SPAN instance
open everyone's watching season I
wouldn't be surprised do they have
earpieces in are they like listening to
30 seconds like uh someone in like a
headquarters all right we have 47 days
the Nays have it by five votes with 25
seconds left this is time that means
they'll stay like Stephen A
Smiths Republicans
Democrats today someone is on a power
trip go home what are we doing go home
I'm betting they don't go home yeah I
mean I think my vote is stay and do your
jobs it's funny but it's just because
Kevin McCarthy doesn't have the votes I
mean you get to leave you stay until you
figure it out can they just do this
forever one happy New Year is a clown
show
nobody gets to leave wow good someone
voted after hit zero you can't do that
what they're still voting it doesn't
matter at least have it that's at least
the greatest government in the world
where the mail-in ballots are coming
yeah that's the greatest joke ever still
it is do you think it's this close by
Just By Design or by like um immersion
like so look they're still they're still
voting I don't know if the time
remaining actually Matters To be honest
either way it's a clown show man
whatever the question was like yeah yeah
they said like an emergency
all the mailing ballots are rolling in
now so it's gonna take at least a week I
know I know the time ran out for the
election but absentee ballots are still
going to be counted yeah anyway yeah all
night it's gonna take a while
Democrats are like the total vote count
is Republicans voting yay I 207
Democrats voting nay 563
297. Nays have it and they still have it
here we go here we go here we go
nobody go home
I would love to bang the game remember
elect
oh here we go I want to go home oh yeah
man oh there's a lot of changes yeah get
out of here you're offering 20 gift
cards
oh come on
no they're clapping democracy Manifest
this is great
they're gonna go home now aren't they
that's scandalous those lazy
bureaucratic beckies they should have
they should have stopped the vote at
zero some someone ran up to a bunch of
four Republicans wouldn't know there's
five no votes come on guys two votes for
stay don't let them leave they're like
this is good TV wow does anybody want to
change their vote and then they do okay
now we can go home oh this is the
American government
[Applause]
they're booing I'd be freaking livid if
I was a Democrat voting no
or anybody voting no on this
[Applause]
like this is life and death
[Music]
I took the uh the counter off the screen
yeah what's what's going on they're
going home going home what's he doing
he's changing his vote
he's like the MVP for tonight everyone
wants to leave leave let everyone else
run the government right yeah for real
you think they give out like sending the
guy with the horns again yeah
you think they give out a Most Valuable
Player tonight like a little MVP award
MVP final game yeah they toss the ball
yeah hey kid catch very area a little
Nancy Pelosi shirt is a bra Hey kid cats
look at this stupid game yo time ran out
they gotta stay so they get to leave I
still can't I like to pass a motion to
not have to work tonight I'm incompetent
what does this mean can they leave if
they if they get a job now yay Has It by
214 and oh by 1 13. until when not by
one what number do they need my name
seven people that still haven't voted
so you must vote Yes I think how come
the Republican hold dots are saying go
home come on
Matt gate said he could vote all night
he probably voted sure that's what I'm
talking about
we need people like Matt gates with with
a lot of energy lock the doors give them
diapers let's let's you know let's fix
this like suspend their pay yeah old
people that don't have the energy and
I'm not I don't have hate towards old
people but anyways people that don't
have the energy to stay up past nine
o'clock and work hours I gotta call
Shenanigans they had 15 minutes to vote
the timer ran out the Nays had it and
this is the this is how it works the
rules don't apply the time is
meaningless they're just like well does
anybody want to change their vote you do
all right we can go home now that you
know the final votali anyone want to
change it oh oh they're yelling again
oh
I'd start blasting some like DMX or
something at this point uh rest in peace
man on this one
this book on this boat the eggs are 260.
no they're not you Liars are 214.
accordingly
wow what are some children dude Congress
is such garbage it's cooler than the
Subaru sucks
they cheated boring meanwhile inflation
is on the road this house was was
cheating they ran out of time and the
Nays had it and then they were like does
anybody want to change their vote and
then a bunch of votes came in after the
time was over yeah where have I seen
that before that's how they do it I've
seen that was the first time I've ever
seen it in real time by the way you were
talking about not offending old people I
think you're geriatric phobic I'm just
gonna I think I should just start
offending them all 100 dude
I'm thinking of my own future because I
don't want to be 85 and people tell me
not to run he's uh octogeneraphobic I
don't know what this is octogenophobic
or over oh 80 plus it's really if you're
85 and you've had stem cells and nmn and
your body is like the 45 year old body
then I'm all about it but if you get
tired at eight o'clock at night get out
of government get out of government
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time